da che l'essere umano è stato
e quindi non parlo solo del
se parlo anche
prima e benché questo nel gergale umano
resilienza abbia pochi anni pochissimi
anni ne avete sentito parlare da 7 ott
dieci anni non di più
in realtà e lucky lisa la conoscevano
perché ad essere umano è stato messo nel
mondo cacciato nel mondo per dire in
maniera ed è gharian a esserci nel mondo
noi abbiamo avuto a che fare con il
fatto di della sua etimologia cioè
resilienza dall'esilio re silvio vuol
dire che erano quelli che venivano lo
sapete non sono stati tanti non frasi
nella storia andavano giù nelle navi per
coloro che risalivano erano i residenti
mentre moltissime persone non l'avevo
neanche la forza di risalire si
lasciavano andare giù si lasciavano
morire è da lì che nasce la parola è
molto antica anche se la usiamo solo in
etimologia moderne vedremo in questo
brevissimo tempo che scorre il
trascorreremo insieme che ci sono delle
cose delle parole alle quali non abbiamo
chiamato cambiato significato
mentre invece all'inizio connotavano una
precisa cosa che noi oggi abbiamo
cambiato spesso in senso negativo
dicevo da che l'essere umano è nato ha
avuto come caratteristica adattativa
alla resilienza non la resistenza e
benché mutuata oggi la parola e
resilienza che avete visto all'inizio e
varie e in alcuni nostri colleghi che
hanno che hanno parlato è mutuata dalla
fisica cioè la capacità di un qualunque
materiale di tornare allo stato
originario
vi do una brutta notizia noi non siamo
materiale noi non siamo l'acciaio noi
non possiamo rispondere a uno stesso
stimolo in maniera identica perché che
sia esso interni spera non è importante
perché qua 130 140 persone quasi 7
miliardi nel mondo allo stesso stimolo
rispondono in maniera differente
totalmente differente e questo perché
siamo esseri umani e gli esseri umani
hanno un dna unico delle impronte
digitali uniche un'unica iride ok è
un'altra cosa che unica
noi in questo momento viventi qua e 7
miliardi di persone
quando siamo l'ultima volta che compare
remo nella storia qui è normale quindi
che non si risponda nello stesso modo e
con lo stesso stimolo perché siamo
esseri umani
una cosa che fa male a me fa meno male
al nostro sindaco o non succede niente
un'altra persona e reagiamo in maniera
differente la capacità che ha sempre
avuto l'uomo di tornare a un punto e non
come un materiale però perché la
residenza non si può comprare in
farmacia da nessuna parte non te la può
spalmare addosso la capacità che ha
avuto sempre di ri salire presuppone nel
concetto che latini hanno dato dire
salendo un qualcosa che significa altro
rispetto a quello meno intendiamo oggi
noi significa cadere se risaliamo da
qualche parte lui siamo caduti e questa
cosa è molto importante perché a che
fare con una parola che l'italiano oggi
e dispregiativa è brutta e non viene più
qualificata che invece studiando bene
l'etimologia della quale ci siamo
dimenticati perché ormai le scuole non
insegnano ma danno solo l'opzione la
parola e rassegnazione la parola la
rassegnazione che cos'è la rassegnazione
la rassegnazione in etimo resine è
qualcosa che significa questo non cedere
sono rassegnato significa questo rompere
un sigillo e quando si rompe un sigillo
qualcosa per chi ha letto l'apocalisse o
altri libri minori gli autori minori rom
per un sigillo vuol dire svelare
qualcosa di szokol dare qualcosa
la stessa parola filosofia sofia da
safest significa appunto mettere in
chiaro il chiaraluce portar fuori non
vuol dire solo sapienza vuol dire questa
cosa qua e allora resilienza e
rassegnazione vanno camminano a spasso
si tengono per mano
luna non esiste senza l'altra io ritengo
che perdere una delle due ci renderebbe
meno umani e il perché è dato dalla
stessa vita che per i greci antichi era
vissuta con un qualcosa sotto che si
chiamava ananke necessità e la vita
procede per cambiamenti procede per
rapidi cambiamenti mutamenti al quale
l'essere umano si è adattato e ha fatto
del suo cambiamento come agente il fatto
di resi gli arti e dear inventarsi ogni
volta e allora che cosa succede quando
tutto muta quando tutto intorno a noi
cambia le possiamo fare due cose o fare
come marinai che si lasciavano morire
oppure risalire cercare di risalire
nella barca e quando qualcuno cerca di
salire sulla barca si si immagina che
qualcuno tenda noi la mano una delle
cose ho capito nella mia nel mio
tragitto di vita che ha passato il mezzo
secolo e questo io ogni volta che ho
avuto bisogno
ho sempre trovato intorno a me mani
capaci di prendermi e di aiutarmi a
tirarmi su chiaro il gesto di chiederà
aiuto l'ho fatto io e il paradosso è
proprio questo che quando non chiedevo
aiuto perché volevo apparire come
superman
ovviamente non c'era nessuno quando ho
avuto il coraggio di sfidare me stesso
alzare la mano
c'erano almeno sei mani che mi hanno
saputo ritirare nella barca e allora
siccome alcune persone che mi conoscono
e quelli che mi conosceranno mi auguro
tutte basta quel whatsapp di persone
intendo sanno che io amo molto leggere e
o e capirete alla fine del mio breve
discorso perché mi piace così tanto
leggere e anche qui c'è un trauma mi
piace leggere e da occidentale
mi piacciono ovviamente tutta la
classica greca da morire ma frequento
anche ai testi fra virgolette sacri
richiamo sacri per chi vuol dire
separato era un sacro nel team in senso
religioso e meno di una settimana fa
capitando siccome non dormo che questa
ciò non dormo comodino mipa mi si apre
il nuovo testamento che conoscete come
vangelo
e c'è un qualcosa che un lettore vero
che non legge basta circa di andare
oltre le parole che sono vergate nero su
bianco su un foglio c'è qualcosa di
altro ora mi capita l'episodio di
giovedì santo gazzè mani ve lo ricordate
orto degli ulivi no orto degli ulivi
gesù e li ha chiesto poco prima a tutti
i suoi vegliate aiutatemi statemi vicino
agli altri dormono è interessante
metafora non ha chiesto veramente e lui
ha oscillato scilla fra due stati
d'animo up and down up and down
contemporaneamente se andate a leggerlo
sia matteo che giovanni e è perfetto è
tra la rassegnazione del compito che lui
sente arrivargli addosso e fare quel
passo che dice sì in questo caso a suo
papà sia fatta la tua volontà ma benché
noi lo sappiamo risorto anche per chi
non ci crede ok lo sappiamo per le
letture lui il fatto che sarebbe risolto
non lo sapeva è questo tutti i teologi
lo dicono noi non lo sapeva quindi
andava incontro
ok ha accettato si è rassegnato ed è
tornato su nella barca per fare quello
per cui lui è nato per essere young
muterà la stessa cosa con il principio
di individuazione cioè diventa ciò che
sei
che è meraviglioso
però abbiamo sentito dalle storie oggi
delle storie incredibili e di solito
tutti noi siamo portati dai giornali che
leggiamo che non leggete perché
l'italiano non legge noto libri che non
si leggono è noto
leggo io per voi non preoccupati 218
l'anno scorso quindi alzo la media fatto
la chievo è però mi sono stancato di
alzare la media così abbia figli di
traumi di conflitti gente che sia dolore
ok ci sta e invece io cambio il
paradigma si può ha mandato più tempo vi
parlo di una cosa si può parlare di
resilienza parlando d'amore è andato
indietro con la mente
chi di voi non è stato travolto una
volta nella vita dell'amore
alzi la mano chi no e chi no cioè tutti
nessuno stare con me innamorato qua
alzate la mano chi è stati innamorati o
meno una volta a tutti tu no ma arriva
non ti preoccupare e come sia finita o
come sta andando non è importante perché
la cosa che fa l'amore l'amore si
patisce la all'amore ci si rassegna la
mia prima amorosa che avevo mio babbo mi
diceva non è quella giusta per te mia
mamma mi diceva non è quella giusta per
te e io secondo voi assolutamente matto
come un cavallo
la amo la desidero allora dicevo la
voglio poi si cambia la voglia ma come
dice freud genio è arrivato qua nella
terra non si sa perché dice
fortunatamente l'amore è una brutta
malattia che ha il pregio di durare poco
e non lo dico io è perché questo guarda
che socrate lo sapeva perché ci
arriviamo è perché quando tu sei tra
fitto e l'invito a pensare alla figura
del cupido come figure cupido è un
innocente
giusto un punto un figlio di computo un
punto che c'è giusto punta al vostro
cuore non come organo inteso da
cartesianamente come organo sul quale
lui scocca la freccia non è che poi come
potete dire punto non farlo una volta
che va tra fitto e va drammatizzato
quello he he via redi arriva un potete
dire niente però quello sballo chimico
quel rock and roll che voi avete nella
testa non può durare le loro scienza
cielo di cola al massimo può durare ma
sei proprio sei bravo 36 mesi dopo di
che succede una cosa tu mette sei
innamorato hai un mondo completamente
differente dei dei fiori vedi le mucche
che volano non ti manca pensi solo a lei
per un principio di utilità sempre di
meno
eh sì è un certo punto si torna e
attenzione socrate ci dice una cosa ce
lo dice in tre dei 31 dialoghi ci dice
che quando si è sparato in guerra
carroll quando si torna perché si torna
noi torniamo incinti chiaro non lo dico
io so che non a parolacce essere incinta
cioè di dice la parola più bella premi
pieni di due il mio me di prima che sta
per partorire un nuovo se è questo nuovo
se sapete che deve fare deve ri nuovo
ricominciare in un vecchio mondo con un
vecchio scenario a capire di nuovo come
mettere i piedi mi fido non mi fido
sono cambiato cambio gusto cambio scarpe
che succede perché per stabilire un
rapporto con l'amata all amato bisogna
riconfigurare le cose bisogna
riconfigurare il tutto perché non dura e
allora c'è per esempio uno studio
bellissimo di arva di harvard di quattro
anni fa dove c'è una stretta
correlazione fra la durata di due
persone che stanno insieme e
l'interdipendenza che hanno c'è più si
reggono da soli più i rapporti durano il
che smonta le teorie che quando si dice
alla persona madio senza di te non vivo
io senza di te muoio senza di te
impazzisco di solito questi rapporti non
durano sono forieri di tempo
no perché l'amore vero quello che si
concreta poi nel rapporto durature lungo
e quando le due persone non sono
indispensabili l'uno con l'altro cioè
stanno in piedi da sole e quando si
incontrano perché questo è un incontro
hanno la piacevolezza di farro e non si
punta l'orologio pensando facciamo
l'amore il venerdì il sabato e non parlo
di un atto fisico io parlo dell'amore in
senso alto del termine fino alla vii
grado
e allora quando si torna dicevo da una
roba traumatizzante che cambia il mondo
come l'amore
bisogna che noi troviamo il nostro
perché allora che cos'è la resilienza
la resilienza la capacità di darsi una
biografia differente ok dove noi ci
consentì a mo di perdonare i nostri
traumi passati e di armarci di un
qualcosa di assolutamente differente che
è molto più potente perché noi abbiamo
vedete perso una grande parola perché
l'abbiamo presa dalla cosa positiva
l'abbiamo messa nel negativo ma questo
accade con quasi tutte le parole in
italiano che non conosciamo più la
parola e vulnerabilità la vita ci
trafigge perché noi siamo vulnerabili
e allora se non la scansiamo se non la
facciamo addormentare se non dicessimo
tutti i giorni io voglio essere perfetto
voglio avere il fisico perfetto la
moglie il marito perfetto l'auto
perfetta e lavoro perfetto i soldi
perfetti che non esiste tutte queste
cose sono un'invenzione una narrazione
sbagliata
noi potremmo parlare invece in quel
parco che facciamo di un nuovo se
un'altra cosa dirgli per esempio che non
sarai mai perfetto non lo potrei essere
ma puoi lottare
puoi combattere e poi guardare la vita è
innamorarti di chi ti pare ma col cuore
e quando l'hai fatto e ancor che tu sia
stato un po male
ringrazia la tua vulnerabilità perché
quella vulnerabilità è da lì che cresce
la resilienza e bene alla vita ma
soprattutto la vulnerabilità ti sta
dicendo una cosa a me a voi le o sei
vivo è per questo che sei vulnerabile
non ce la possiamo togliere però vi
voglio lasciare con delle parole e vi
racconto una bellissima storia
io sono stato non per entrare in
particolare alla nove anni ho rischiato
di morire subito un'operazione di 13 ore
e mezzo e o se il titolo il dialogo dei
miei genitori con il medico e diciamo
che era 50 50 e benché a 9 anni tu non
abbia la facoltà di capire che cos'è la
morte
credetemi fa un brutto effetto quando ti
fanno l'anestesia
dopo 13 ore e mezzo di intervento ci ho
messo sei ora svegliarmi
il medico buon anima che mi salvò la
vita anche l'udito in parte col quale ho
un bellissimo rapporto perché mi curo
per la prima volta due mesi e mezzo e
quindi mi ha portato in vita per i
prossimi quattro per i futuri 14 anni
un giorno ed ecco perché mi piace
leggere e tutto svelato non le mappe
concettuali poi tornano mi regalo un
libro ed era un libro di poesie e mi
disse caro il mio super leo questo te lo
regalo io ce l'ho ancora a casa con la
sua firma
leggilo nei momenti più difficili e
leggendo trovai una poesia di lord
tennyson che si chiama ulisse dalla
quale vi dico solo la parte finale
perché lunga e perdonate l'emozione
perché io vado ancora quei momenti tutto
fasciato e dice venite e amici cari non
è troppo tardi per cercare un mondo più
nuovo spingetevi al largo e sedendo
belin ordine per quotate i sono risolti
perché il mio scopo consiste nel
navigare oltre il tramonto e i bagni di
tutte le stelle occidentali finché io
muoia potrebbe succedere che gli abissi
c inghiottiranno potremmo forse toccare
le isole felici e vedere il grande
achille che noi conosciamo una volta e
anche se molto è stato preso molto
ancora aspetta e anche se noi non siamo
ora quella forza che in giorni antichi
mosse terra e cieli ciò che siamo
siamo una gual indole gli eroici cuori
fiaccati dal tempo e dal fato ma forti
nella volontà di combattere cercare
trovare e di non cedere mai
grazie